what's good Josh your boy ddg and these
are my favorite snacks
[Music]
all right my first snack is honey bun I
got into Honey Buns because I used to
sell them in school I used to make like
probably like 100 between 50 and 100 a
day
so that was pretty good for like a you
know 16 17 year old so these are like my
top sellers but then I got to a point
where I started eating them and I just
grew a love for Honey Buns I feel like
these are like a good go-to snack it's
like a donut in a way I'm actually
trying to stay away from sugar
but I'm gonna take a bite for y'all
[Music]
that was fire
Hot Cheetos Classics can't go wrong with
these
Classics
it depends I don't really know the
difference I like to eat spicy food so I
can handle the spice I know y'all do hot
ones so you know
you know I I did like the one chip
challenge before
jalapenos I get it on everything I eat
this is like spice
oh [ __ ]
did we do it again
Jesus
Jesus is like my this is my go-to snack
I feel like they're more on the healthy
side even though it's not really healthy
yeah I took these to school a lot for
two reasons I kind of ate school lunch
most of my like high school career or
whatever you want to call it when I did
bring lunches or when I brought snacks
from school say I was running late on
eating breakfast I always have cheeses I
always bring cheeses
all right it's fine
Takis this might be a hot take but I
rank Takis over Hot Cheetos
I don't know I like Takis a lot
I feel like you got a better taste and
then a lot of people ain't gonna
say this but Hot Cheetos tried to take
their flow with a little lime flavor
talking started it and I like talking
because you know they switching up the
colors and all that like blue Takis
green Takis all type you know what I'm
saying so that's why I feel like Takis
is better
I'll be doing the mukbang with artists
it's a way to let the fans embody the
song more you know because they get to
see y'all interact get to see me
interact with somebody else I'm doing
mukbang with somebody they get to see
y'all really homies and I feel like they
support the song More
just a good way to break the ice
Nutri grain
I said nutrigrain I'm tripping Nature
Valley crunchy oatsun you know what I'm
talking about granola bars
[Music]
I started eating these ever since I
turned 23. I started feeling like cracks
in my bones that I didn't usually feel
so it's like okay let me start eating a
little healthy when I eat this I don't
feel it's bad you know what I'm saying
like when I ate that honey bun earlier
I kind of felt bad a little bit
they slept on two these are very good
actually you don't rip the whole thing
a lot of people they just rip it open
and they wonder why the crumbs going
everywhere you gotta open it halfway
make the CRS open
Chrome's trying to come out already
so you might get a little bit of crumbs
but
but then we
man
the crumbs is annoying for sure
especially if you like if you're in the
car or some [ __ ] you don't want no
crowns all over your seat it's just
really about where you eat them at I try
to eat them at home
yeah I didn't expect this [ __ ] to come
on I ain't gonna lie even if I just do
like this
Reese's Puffs classes
it's really on preference how much milk
you want to put inside your cereal but I
know it's some weird people out there in
this world they put the milk in first
that's just weird
foreign
School while I walk to the bus stop
I'm like a chocolate lover I like eating
chocolate I feel like it's not too
peanut buttery you see I got mostly
chocolate ones right now
and then I go over here and now I got
mostly peanut butter ones so say you're
not feeling peanut butter today
you go ahead you scoop and get you a
nice little predominantly chocolate
scoop
and that's gonna make your cereal
taste more chocolatey
all right y'all appreciate y'all kicking
in with me watching me break down my
snacks be sure to go listen to my brand
new album the deluxe is out now major
features on there great music great
songs it's not me it's you on all
platforms go stream it
[Music]